if you tried to buy a house recently in
this country suddenly prices are
out of control and not just in the
places where you'd think they would be
texas florida people moving out of
failing states into thriving states
they're up everywhere they're up in san
jose california which is already way
overvalued for like 20 years
but they're still going up homes are
going for
a lot above asking price everywhere
with his new york city office shut due
to the pandemic and looking for more
space for his family
in the summer of 2020 justin goldberg
and his wife jessica
put their three-bedroom bloomfield new
jersey home on the market
the house listed for 399 thousand
dollars with multiple six-figure offers
over the asking price
the house sold for five hundred and
forty two thousand dollars
over a hundred and forty thousand more
than what the couple was asking for
but the family then found themselves
struggling to find a new home
with little inventory on the market the
couple signed a one-year lease on a
rental
and on the advice from their realtor
they then modified their house search
from looking for a move-in ready home to
a fixer-upper
well that is happening everywhere it
doesn't seem normal there's been a lot
of moving within this country but we're
not watching
a conventional housing market there's
something else going on
in fact there is the wall street journal
in a recent piece found that private
equity firms like blackrock are
purchasing entire neighborhoods of
single-family homes
and turning them into rentals in houston
for example big investors are now
accounting for a quarter
of home purchases what does this mean
for the country pedro gonzalez's
associate editor at chronicles we're
happy to have him on tonight to assess
this pedro thanks so much
for coming up so what you're seeing here
the big picture
is the bedrock of american democracy was
always
independence the burger class people own
their own homes mow their own lawns they
own something they're vested in the
country
and that is changing and we're becoming
at high speed a nation of renters
what are the implications of this well
look
eisenhower said in his farewell address
that you and i
and our government must avoid the
impulse to live only for today
to plunder for our own convenience and
ease the precious resources of tomorrow
plundering the future is what financial
institutions like blackrock are doing by
buying up tons of real estate
freddie mac's 2019 housing survey found
that 40 of renters expect to never own a
home
and we can expect that number to rise
homeownership gives people a stake in
society it's a way to build generational
wealth
it's the foundation of the middle class
and part of the american dream
and permanent capital is now robbing
americans of that dream
singing you'll own nothing and be happy
they're killing the dream and giving us
a nightmare of dispossession
and they're doing this to underwrite
pensions and pad bottom lines
by raising housing prices gobbling up
single-family homes and fueling another
speculative investor-driven home price
bubble
that if and when it bursts the same
people they priced out of homes will end
up
subsidizing the bailout and by the way
many of these same institutions
also promote progressive policies like
environmental policies that also raise
the price of housing
undermine the second amendment like
blackrock is doing
and push for more immigration as jp
morgan asset management is doing
immigration also raises the price of
housing of course and all of these
things are good for business because
a mass of indebted and disarmed serfs
are much more easily managed
but we're not meant to be slaves to
capital and markets these things are
tools for our enrichment
and when people and society turn them
like knives against the rest of society
we have a right and in fact an
obligation to fight back and call it
what it is
selfish destructive greed cutting at the
heart of america
man i'm going to print that out because
that was
everything about that was true and too
rarely said pedro gonzalez thank you for
your clarity i appreciate it thanks so
much for having me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else